He would take three breaths
while he is drinking. So, he
would drink and then, you know,
pause and drink and pause. So,
he wouldn't drink altogether.
He would take, drink
intermittently, incrementally,
he would drink down. He
wouldn't you know, chug things.
Rather, he would drink them
slowly. Here, it's mentioned
three times. This isn't, of
course, with everything.
Perhaps a person is drinking
something small or just
going to take a sip of
something But what the point
here is is that he would not
drink something altogether. All
at once. It's in Muslim the
prophet tells us that we should
not drink altogether.
He says that drinking gulps,
drinking, something
incrementally is safer,
healthier for the body. It is
more satisfying etcetera. being
that we're discussing this
issue. It's mentioned here
three times. There's a there's
a kind of a trait that people
have or accustomed that when a
person eats something, they
usually eat. and freeze. So,
they'll take three dates for
instance, right? Or five dates.
something of that sort. There's
nothing in the sunnah having to
do with numbers with regards to
eating. Many people think it's
a sunnah to eat three dates or
five dates or seven dates
rather than two or four even
numbers. And there's nothing
indicating that in the prophet
as the scholars have mentioned.
Rather, a person can eat as
many as they like. What's
important is that a person
maintain etiquette during
eating as he would with
anything else.
Says
[Silence]
Rather, if he dislikes
something, he would merely
refrain from eating it. And
sometimes, he would explain
this and express it saying,
Meaning that I do not like
this. I don't eating it. I
don't want to eat it. Right? Or
rather than I don't this
more I don't desire this.
It's a better translation. I
don't find myself desiring this
dish. This is very important.
Food in general is a blessing
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It's very ungrateful for a
person too.
speak bad about any food that
they eat A person has a dish in
front of them If they don't
it, then just don't eat
it. That's all. If you don't
it, someone else may like
it. It is poor etiquette with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
disparage food. Or anything
that is disparaging. Right? And
taste is is very unique and
tailor fitted. Some people like
things that others don't. Some
people to eat things that
others find repulsive and vice
versa. Therefore,
me not liking something doesn't
make it necessarily bad or
doesn't make it necessarily
distasteful. It just means that
it doesn't agree with how I
perceive the world. So, it's a
very it's a very broad thing
and a person should never
disparage food. This is poor
etiquette with Allah.
Ida
the
[Silence]
vinegar is the best the best
dressing for food or for bread.
Now, obviously, vinegar is
something that is acceptable in
its place. It's not the best
dressing a person can have but
the reason why he said this is
that when he asked for
something to dip his bread
into, he was told that we don't
have anything except for and so
he that is the best. This is to
make the person who offered it
to him feel better. This is to
to him feel better. Not
necessarily saying that it is
the best out of all the choices
that a person could possibly
have. Rather he said this as a
gesture of goodwill and a kind
statement to his wife. Who
offered him this.
He says
[Silence]
conceal their actions and
that's fine. They want to fast
and have that fast to be
something private between
themselves and Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. They don't want to
announce it to everyone.
However, if a person invites
you to eat and you just say no,
no, I don't want anything. No,
no. This may be a little bit
rude or a person may interpret
this incorrectly misinterpret
it. Therefore, the prophet
would explain why. He would say
in Islam, I'm fasting. Meaning,
otherwise, I would have
accepted your invitation but
I'm fasting and that is usually
sufficient for most people
because most Muslims respect
worship. He also
encour
aged that anyone who is
fasting and has been invited to
a meal or to eat something. And
they wish to continue their
fast that they should at least
make dua for the person. Should
at least make dua for the
person that invited them. And
if a person is not fasting and
they are able to, they should
accept invitation. Very
important to stand that
accepting an invitation, if
there is no, if there are no
particular circumstances
preventing a person from
accepting invitation, then they
should accept the invitation of
anyone who invites them, right?
They should they should accept
the invitation and honor the
invitation of anyone who
invites them. Now, there could
be a reason why you cannot
accept an invitation One of
those reasons being that you're
in a position of authority and
people, if you allow people to,
you know, wine and dine you, it
will affect the the sincerity
of your position, right? But
let's say there's a judge and
people invite this judge over
that happened to have a case
that is going to be brought
before that judge. Is he to
accept that invitation? Of
course not. That would be that
would be unethical. There are
times when a person may reject
an invitation or times when a
person may reject a gift.
That's one example. Another
example is that a person is
being invited by someone who is
reproachful. Menen, someone who
is reproachful. What does that
mean? Meaning that if they give
you something, they're going to
keep reminding you about it,
right? How do you that
thing? I gave you. How do you
think, what do you think of it?
Do you use it often? What do
you think of? Oh, I gave this
guy such and such. Remember
when I gave, this is called
reproachfulness. This is called
right? And this is a major sin
in Islam. The prophet
tells us that three types of
people, Allah will not look at
them, speak to them, or purify
them on the day of
resurrection. One of them, the
person who reproachful with
regards to things that they
give others. This is the type
of person who falls into this.
The prophet would usually
accept gifts. Actually, this is
one of the traits that is
mentioned about him in the
previous books, Canaan,
Sallallahu And this is what
Salman al Pharisee had him with
before he accepted Islam. So
Salman heard of a prophet that
is going to emerge from amongst
the palm trees. Regard as a
reference to Medina, Yethrib.
and Salman who traveled to
Yathrib and lived there for a
long time before the prophet
arrival in anticipation of his
arrival. How many tribes were
there of the Jewish tribes in
Medina? Does anyone know? Bree,
that's correct. Three Jewish
tribes. Are those Jewish tribes
that were there
are they native to Medina
Budaism usually it came from
the Middle East from the Arab
Peninsula. Judaism originates
from where?
Well, if we look back, Musa
Alaihi Salam was where? Egypt
and then he led his people
towards where? Towards
Palestine, right? Right? So,
that's where the Jews and the
prophets of the Jews were. Now,
what were these three tribes
doing in the Arab Peninsula,
living in Medina? What were
they doing over there? They
were waiting for the next
prophet but not just for the
next prophet. They knew that
the last prophet is going to be
from the loins of Ismael.
and they were indignated by
this. They felt he should
be from this hack, from the
lineage of his hack. They
actually moved there and
resided there for decades,
maybe even centuries.
hoping
that if they went there
and had a lot of offspring,
maybe one of their descendants,
one of their children would
actually be that prophet. This
was their attempt. So, when
they arrived at Medina, they
started having lots and lots of
kids. Hoping that one of their
kids would end up being that
prophet. So, when the prophet
arrived and he was the
messenger, they were not very
happy about that. Hence, the
disputes and the hypocrite and
the backstabbing which ensued.
From the Jews of Medina towards
the prophet and his companions.
Now, Salman who heard about
this prophet that is going to
emerge from amongst the palm
trees. That's a reference to
Medina which was called at the
time because Yethrib was known
for its palm trees, alright?
And so, Salman took a very
long, arduous journey till he
finally made it. Into Medina
and he was actually living as a
servant there. and he heard
about the prophet and he knew
that one of the traits
mentioned in the previous
scriptures, the previous
revelations of Allah and the
the literature of the people of
the book that one of the traits
of this prophet is that he does
not eat anything that is from
charity but he does accept and
eat from that which is a gift.
Oh Salman approached him
presented some food to him and
said, this is it, this is
charity.
so the prophet told his
companions that were around him
to eat it and he did not
partake in it. And said the man
returned the next day and
offered him food, a dish, you
know, a meal. But this time, he
said, it is a gift. And so the
prophet ate it and shared it
with his companions. Prophet
would accept gifts. Somebody
gave him a gift, he would
accept it. However, After a
while, he stopped accepting
gifts except from certain
particular people. Why? Because
many people knew that one of
the Sunan of the prophet
Sallallahu Al is that he would
do what is called
A man that a person does what
is that if somebody gives you
something, you should give give
them something in return. And
usually that's something that
you give them should be better
than what they gave you. This
is called and it's a of the
prophet
Now, being that his way was
that he would he was a he was
somebody who would you know, he
would return the favor if you
will He would usually return it
with something better and that
was actually the way of many of
the Arabs at that time. and so,
some people would give him
gifts hoping that he would give
them something more valuable in
return, right? and so the
prophet received the gift from
a man as is mentioned in
Bukhari. He was given a gift by
a man. And so he Caphael, he
gave him a gift in return. But
the gift that he gave him in
return was not to the
expectation of the receiver.
And so he became kind of
belligerent. He became a little
bit rude in his demeanor. And
the
said, indeed by Allah, I will
not accept the gift anymore
from anyone except for certain
people and so he named them.
What does this tell us? This
tells us that if you are being
given a gift with worldly
strings attached. You are not
obligated to accept that gift.
who are being given a gift with
worldly strings attached. You
are not obligated to accept
that gift.
let's say an imam of the
Masjid. Everybody wants to give
him gifts. Oh, I got this for
you, Imam, oh Sheikh, oh Imam.
However, this imam is in charge
of being fair, and in charge of
dealing with issues other than
just leading salah. it eh
behooves this imam to not
accept gifts usually. A judge
would not accept gifts usually.
Etcetera. Because these gifts
are actually incentives. See
what happens when you throw
money at people. Things usually
get bad. They don't get better.
Anytime you start to charge
things with money, it usually
spoils, you know, it poisons
the well. Now, for instance,
we see politicians who are who
whom their campaigns are funded
by particular people, right?
have donators that will donate
huge amounts of money hundreds
of thousands, sometimes
millions of dollars to a
particular candidate's
campaign. This doesn't come for
free. This is not a free meal.
This is not a free lunch. Those
donors are expecting something
in return. A person has certain
amount of money donated to his
campaign and then he is
actually elected Well, his
donors are going to come for
their they're going to come to
reap the fruits of their
donation. If they have a
pharmaceutical company, they're
going to want legislation
passed and pushed that will
make things easier for their
pharmaceutical company or the
meat industry or whatever it
is. This is very dangerous
because when everything is
based on money, we have a big
problem because money is going
to be leverage that will
control people. Prophet
strictly prohibited anyone who
is working for the state to
accept a gift, a gift, quote
unquote. Muslim there was a man
who was commissioned by the
prophet to collect zakah.
people that would collect
Zakad, the prophet would
handpick them and they would go
out to the different tribes and
the different people and the
different homes and the
different villages and they
would collect the zakah and if
it is from the people of the
book, they would collect the
and
One of them came back one
day with the zakah that he had
collected. Zakah at that time
was collected from whatever the
person was giving zakat on. So,
if it was from harvest, it
would be, you know whatever was
reaped from that harvest, if it
was livestock, it would be, you
know, goats and sheep, and
camels, and oxen, and so forth,
and so he returned to the
prophet to deliver this zakah
that he had collected to to the
treasury. And so he brought
whatever the was, and he said,
but these things here, these
are mine. Somebody gave them to
me as a gift. Prophet heard
about this and became very
upset about it. Said, This is
truly a gift for you Then why
didn't you wait in your own
home for them to bring you this
gift? Meaning, the only reason
that they are that this person
received this gift is why?
Because that person is.
electing Zakat, right? So, this
guy comes every year to collect
the zakah. So, we butter him up
a little bit. We give him, you
know, here's the zakat and by
the way, this is a gift for
you. are they giving him this
gift? Are they giving him this
gift because they personally
him? If they were giving
him this gift because they
personally liked him, then why
didn't they deliver this gift
to his house? Why did they wait
for him to come and collect
Zachah for them to give him
this gift? No. What happens
here is corruption seeps into
the government agency. Which
means that he comes to collect
this year and we give him our
portion of zakah. And then next
and we give him a gift and we
give him a gift and then we
start looking for payment on
that gift, right? So, one year,
he'll come and we'll say, you
know, I'm a little light,
things are tough this year,
things are not so easy, and
he'll say, you know what, don't
worry about it, and only take a
portion or not take what is
due. It'll start to be soft on
the people that gave them these
gifts. This is corruption. This
is impermissible. A person who
is going to be leveraged by a
gift, person who is going to be
leveraged by a meal or anything
else, they are required in
Islamic law to turn down this
gift, to turn down this meal.
Now, that's not all the time.
Obviously, the prophet was the
judge and the imam and he
accepted gifts from people and
he accepted and honored
people's invitations However,
This would be handpicked people
that he knew were not going to
try to leverage him or did not
have any ulterior motives in
giving this gift or in giving
this feeding this meal,
etcetera. This is an important
point. And many of our teachers
would very much very much
discourage us from attending
and honoring many invitations
that people would give because
first of all you are on the
receiving end which always
already puts you at a
disadvantage. Second of all,
you are now making yourself
just everyone else. People
will start to not
not hold you high as high at
esteem as they would if you
were novel. What does that
mean? Meaning, if a scholar
sits with everyone and jokes
with everyone and is always
going out with them and doing
things that everyone does. His
his esteem will go down with
people. They can't help it.
That's just how human beings
are, right? It's very important
for a scholar to be in high
esteem amongst people. So, that
they accept what he has to say,
that they accept Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's words and
the prophet words.
very rarely are things given
without strings attached. This
is what is referred to as the
free lunch, right? Free lunch.
Meaning that usually people,
not all people, not all times,
but usually, people give gifts
or when people invite or when
people do these things, they're
looking for reciprocity on that
gift. There are strings
attached. They have a reason, a
motive for doing that. It's
kind of So, a person has
to be very vigilant as to what
these motives are. If these
motives are to please Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, if these
motives are to for the sake of
brotherhood, for the sake of
sisterhood, for the sake of
community, for the sake of
pleasing Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, that's great. That is
that is a those are strings
which are attached to the
afterlife and that is fine but
when the return on that gift is
leverage or the return on that
gift is favors or the return on
that gift is that is where it
becomes problematic. So, a
person needs to be vigilant of
that. Ib He says,
for in
The prophet
[Silence]
came with us. If you wish that
he come with that's fine and if
not, he will return. Sometimes,
a person invites a another and
they want just that person to
come. Sometimes, people aren't
comfortable with other people
coming to their home. They are
very selective as to who comes.
And if you just show up with
someone, most likely, they're
not going to say, no, I don't
want this guy here. He has to
go back, right? this is what is
called you are basically you
are basically shaming a person
into doing something that they
don't want to do and this is
not permissible in Islam. You
are not to put someone into a
position where they cannot say
no. Or if they do it will be to
their detriment. You might as
well force them. You might as
well compel them to do
something. And so, it's
important that if we are
invited by someone that we are
sure as to the confines or the,
you know, the expected
what the what the limits or the
confines of this invitation
are. a person invites you and
you think that you're going to
bring someone else, you should
say. is it okay if I bring
this person or that person? But
you should also read the person
that's inviting you. And you
should read if this person
maybe they want to discuss
something personal. Maybe
they're inviting you for some
reason because they have some
business to discuss with you or
maybe they're just a very
private person. And they don't
a lot of people coming
over. Whatever it is. People
have different reasons and it's
their right. I mean it's their
home and they can have whomever
they choose and their home. So,
we should always make sure that
we understand the invitation
and we understand the extent of
that invitation and we should
never shame people into doing
or accepting something that we
know they're uncomfortable
with. Right? So, let's say for
instance, you know, I invite
you to my home. and you know
that I'm a very private person
and I don't really invite many
people to my home and I invite
you specifically and then, when
I open the door, you come over,
I open the door and there you
are standing with two or three
other guys that I don't know or
guys that I hadn't invited.
Most likely, I'm I'm going to
say, yeah, come in, you know,
to everyone because I'm not
going to tell people to leave.
But that is a position that is
not permissible to put a person
into. Where they feel shy or
ashamed to say no. This is type
of compelling which is
impermissible in Islam. So, we
should be very sensitive as to
the as to the expectations of
our host. Another thing that is
very important when it comes to
accepting invitations is that
we control our eyes when we go
into people's homes. something
that a lot of people don't
realize or think about. We are
to control our eyes when we are
in a person's home. What does
that mean? When you go into
someone's home, the scholars
mention that you should only
look where the person expects
you to look. Things that are
appropriate and we're not just
speaking about maybe women that
are in the house or something
that. Just in general,
being Snoopy. Looking looking
at everything that they have,
checking out the different
rooms. You know, you walk by an
open door, you're peeking
inside what's going on over
there. People are walking in
the background. You're checking
them out. This is very bad
manners. And Ibn Abbas has
mentioned this to his
companions. When they went and
accepted an invitation of
another who had invited Ibn
Abbas and he brought some of
his students with him. And when
they enter the home they were
very very liberal with their
sight and very liberal with
their eyes and so even I best
rebuke them for this and he
mentions the verse in which
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sees and knows the treachery of
the eyes and what the hearts
conceal and so he considered
treachery of the eyes to be
that a person look where they
where it is inappropriate for
them to look. Another thing
that Many people do and they're
unaware of is that when they
attend or they honor an
invitation When you go to your
host your host brings you into
their home or wherever it is
that your host has invited you
to. It's very important to take
specific direction from your
host. Very important to take
host So, for instance, your
host brings you to his home and
there's a little chair here and
a nice, big, comfortable chair
over there, right? And your
host tells you to sit in the
big, comfortable chair. Many
people say, no, no, no, I'm
good. I'll sit in this little
chair. I'll sit on this little
stool over here to be humble.
That is not good at it. You sit
where your host tells you to
sit, right? Maybe your host
wants you to sit there because
your back is to a hallway that
is used and there are people
that need to get by without
being seen. Maybe your host
wants you to sit there because
this chair is wet. Maybe your
host wants you to sit there
because he wants to honor his
guest and you need to allow him
to do that, right? We are
encouraged by Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to honor our guests.
whoever believes in Allah in
the last day, then he is to
honor his guest And as a guest,
you are to allow your host to
honor you, right? If he cooks
something, you eat it. If he
presents something to you, you
accept it. If he tells you to
sit somewhere, you sit that
place. This is to the point
that even scholars of amongst
the companions would not lead
salah in their host homes. That
is that the prophet
he had mentioned that he says
Muslim
[Silence]
another person's home. So,
let's say a person is a
scholar, he comes over to just
a regular person's house.
Naturally, if we were outside
of this person's home, who
would lead salah? Obviously,
the scholar, the person who is
more versed in salah in Quran.
However, the of the prophet is
that the person who owns the
home, the host, he is the
person that should lead salah.
And the person who attends, the
guests, no matter who he is,
should not lead that person in
salah, unless that person
insists or gives him
permission. and another thing
that the prophet said, he said
and no man is to sit on the
man, another man's furniture
without his permission, without
his consent, right? So, Well,
you go over to someone's house,
your host tells you to sit
here, please, or sit over here.
Al Adep,
True etiquette is to be it's
the peace subordinate in that
position. To be obedient.
Whatever your host tells you,
that's what you do. Oftentimes,
we will go over to people's
homes and we'll see that
they're bringing out trays of
food for instance and we
want to jump up and we want to
help them again. And they say,
no, sit down, please. I'll take
care of it. No, no, I got it,
I'll take care of it, you know.
Before you know it, the guests
are doing the dishes and all
kinds of stuff. This is
impermissible. This is wrong. A
person should list unto his
host
you're not a guest at your
son's home. Speaking about
being a guest at a host home
You invite me to your house,
right? You're going to lead
salah and I'm going to do
whatever you tell me to do. Sit
here, I sit here, wash your
hands here, I'm going to wash
my hands here and anytime I
pick up that, you know, the
party's over and it's time to
go home, I'm going to take
myself home, I'm not going to
stay past that. If a father
goes over to a son's house,
this is not a guest. This is
family member. right? If you're
sitting in your host's home and
he says, please sit down, you
know, don't don't touch
anything or picking up the
dishes, you know? There, your
host is commanded by Allah to
honor his guest. And the guest
needs to allow the host to
honor him. Correct? He can't be
stubborn and insist that you're
going to run another man's home
in his home. It's very
disrespectful actually. make
sure that you are obedient, you
are subordinate, you're in
another man's home, you're in
another man's castle. Whatever
he tells you to do, you do.
that is enough for tonight.